STEPHANIE WONG: Hey,
it's Stephanie Wong,
and welcome to "Season
of Scale," a new series
I created to help you
build skill and resilience
into your design patterns.
Today I'll be covering the
basics behind how to do that.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With everything going
on in the world,
there's been undeniable
disruption for businesses.
Social isolation around
the globe has settled in,
and traditional
brick-and-mortar companies
have been forced
to shift operations
into an online space, while
already online companies are
seeing a massive spike
in daily traffic.
This might have put
a lot of pressure
on you to adapt and evolve
your online architectures
and maybe face the
realization that you're
both resource- and
business-constrained.
This rang true for Critter
Junction, a multiplayer gaming
company that's gained
massive popularity
in the last few months.
Online players can
interact with one
another in a virtual
world that follows
life simulation as a critter.
Building and operating a
gaming stack at this scale
requires a lot of
careful planning.
So my team and I are
stepping in to help
Critter Junction revisit
their design practices
for ultimate global success.
So far, Critter
Junction has been
great at running individual
machines on premise,
but hasn't really been
able to automatically
scale to many machines to handle
peaks and dips in traffic.
At times, they end up running
over-utilized machines
and other times run
underutilized machines
and haven't built resilience
into their architecture.
A failure in networking,
image updates, or peak load
could lead to a disruption in
their game players' experience.
On top of that, Critter
Junction has its own business
and operational pressures.
Their CTO is all
about becoming more
agile to adapt to
fluctuating user demands,
their developers are
focusing on reducing
the time it takes to
investigate failures,
and their operators
care about finding ways
to automatically
recover from failures.
This is a lot to think about.
But let's start by
first explaining what
scalability and resilience are.
Scalability is the measure
of a system's ability
to handle varying
amounts of work
by adding or removing
resources from the system.
For example, a scalable
web app can not only
work well with one user, but
also with 100 million users.
And it can gracefully handle
peaks and dips in traffic.
The good news is
the cloud gives you
the flexibility to adjust the
resources consumed by an app.
The bad news--
without proper design,
you could end up using more
resources than you need,
like what Critter
Junction's done on premise.
What you want, instead,
is to reduce costs
by removing underutilized
resources without compromising
performance or user experience.
That being said, even scalable
apps can face disruptions.
Without resilience built
in, system failures
can throw a wrench
in your operations.
Resilience means designing
to withstand failures.
A resilient app is
one that continues
to function despite failures
of system components.
And this requires
planning at all levels
of your architecture.
It influences how you lay out
your infrastructure and network
and how you design your
data storage and app.
It even extends to
people and culture.
Let's face it.
Building and operating
resilient apps
is hard, especially for
distributed gaming stacks,
which means multiple layers
of infrastructure and networks
and services.
So over the season, we're
going to walk Critter Junction
through Google Cloud and
design best practices to help
them build both scalable
and resilient apps.
All in all, these patterns
and best practices
will fall into three themes.
Automation, because automating
your infrastructure,
provisioning, testing,
and app deployments
increases consistency and speed
and minimizes human error.
Loose coupling, because
treating your system
as a collection of loosely
coupled independent components
gives you flexibility
and resilience.
And data-driven design, because
collecting metrics to your app
is critical.
Decisions about when
to scale your app
or when a particular
service is unhealthy
need to be based on data.
These themes are going to be
crucial to laying a stronger
foundation to scale
and withstand failures.
Mistakes and outages
happen, but Critter Junction
is on a mission to
improve the design
of their app architecture
and dev processes.
Stay tuned to find out how.
And remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]